bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes invités politiques samatan des
petites et du val de reporter général de
la commission des finances à l'assemblée
nationale député à la république en
marche évidemment vous êtes avec nous
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenter l par fabrice
lessard au nom du groupe et bravo jean
fabrice aurieng bonjour les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france
évidemment le groupe ebra olivier
ferrand a donc annoncé hier les
nouvelles mesures du gouvernement pour
lutter contre cette cinquième vague on a
vu des durées de validité de tests qui
sont réduits la campagne de vaccination
de rappel pour la troisième dose qui est
ouverte dès les prochains jours un
passani terre qui sera conditionnée à
cette troisième dose est ce que
finalement on n'est pas dans des mesures
qui sont impasse vaccinale déguisé
laurent saint martin non puisque la
vaccination n'est pas le seul moyen
d'avoir le passé à lutter on continue
sur la même logique il est valable
uniquement 24 heures c'est compliqué
écoutez on garde la même logique la
vaccination n'est pas obligatoire on
fait confiance aux français il ya encore
des millions de français qui ne sont pas
vaccinés effectivement on encourager en
incite à la vaccination la plus large
possible notre ligne n'a pas changé mais
face à la recrudescence de l'épidémie
face aux nombres de contagion qu'il ya
effectivement il faut resserrer un
certain nombre de critères pour qu'il y
ait toujours plus de vaccination et
surtout encore une fois on le répète que
chacun soit plus vigilant vous allez
depuis le début de cette crise ce sont
des vagues successives
et puis nous mêmes nous sommes humains
et puis il y à des périodes où on se
relâche un petit peu et c'est naturel
parce que c'est moralement épuisant la
période que nous vivons est donc c'est
aussi la responsabilité du gouvernement
de dire attention là il faut se
ressouder ensemble faire plus attention
gestes barrières
cette crise nous assumons que nous ne
pouvons pas
vernay de façon autoritaire sur le sujet
de la lutte contre le virus nous le
faisons en accompagnant l'ensemble des
français pour pouvoir vivre ensemble on
le fait malheureusement avec
déconfinement ça a été le début de la
crise aujourd'hui nous évitons les
fermetures mais cela doit passer par du
rappel vaccinal pour ceux qui sont
vaccinés et nous espérons que ce soit le
plus tôt france est possible ou alors
par le passé ni terre pour l'ensemble
des français martin vous êtes vous
donniez ce mot un de resserrement l'étau
se resserre comme un moteur de ceux qui
ne veulent pas se faire vacciner non pas
pas de ceux qui ne peuvent pas ceux qui
ne veulent vous portez vous en tant que
parlementaire quel regard sur ces ces
personnes qui ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner ce sont c'est de
l'irresponsabilité
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'en ne se
vaccinant pas on se met en danger soi
même et on continue à mettre en danger
les autres ça nous continuons à le dire
il faut continuer à le répéter mais
pardon d'avoir ce défaut éternelle je
crois en la force de conviction les
français continuent à se faire vacciner
malheureusement nous lisons dans la
presse quotidien régional la vôtre
notamment des drames qui se passe des
drames familiaux qui se passe parce que
les personnes ne sont pas vaccinés
par exemple mais c'est effroyable c'est
dramatique alors que le vaccin il est
accessible alors qu'il est gratuit dans
notre pays tant que c'est insupportable
de se dire que des familles se met en
danger meurt parce qu'elles ne sont pas
vaccinés donc oui au fur et à mesure de
plus en plus de français se vaccine et
nous atteignons parmi les proportions
les plus importantes de vacciner dans
notre pays et c'est heureux mais il faut
continuer là-dessus et surtout il faut
le dire maintenant mais ça va être
obligatoire avec la validité du passani
terre qui va être conditionné à cette
dose de rappel qui évidemment est une
nouvelle sécurité supplémentaires les
mesures qui passe mal dans les outre-mer
notamment dans les antilles en
guadeloupe et en martinique où il ya des
manifestations des violences est ce que
le gouvernement est en train de se faire
déborder par la situation dans les
antilles non le gouvernement est aux
responsabilités aux antilles c'est
d'abord aujourd'hui un sujet d'ordre
public
la priorité c'est de maintenir et de
rétablir l'ordre public
c'est pas un sujet de santé là ce dont
on parle c'est d'abord effectivement
laissé les forces de l'ordre faire leur
travail de maintien de l'ordre public
c'est d'abord ça la priorité pourrait
bien que la situation sanitaire est
parfois un alibi pour certaines
contestations et voir cassage et est
incertain de débordements qui sont
inacceptables le sujet sanitaires il pas
nouveau en outre mer le ministre de la
santé le ministre de l'outre-mer il
était au mois d'août le suivent au
quotidien c'est évidemment un enjeu
comme je viens de vous le dire le sujet
là très contemporain ce sujet d'abord
d'ordre public à sébastien lecornu de
régler la problématique de l'ordre
public en outre-mer qui
me lisent et outre mer va y retourner
très prochainement mais faut arrêter ça
ça pardon mais si la petite polémique
que le ministre d outre mer il y a
maintenant ou dans quelques jours alors
qu'il est quotidiennement
quotidiennement en lien évidemment avec
les autorités de l'état et avec
l'ensemble des collectivités d'outre-mer
en communication tous les jours
évidemment c'est son métier pour suivre
la situation et surtout pour accompagner
les outre-mer dans l'effort de
d'accompagnement que nous devons faire
pour que les français là bas puissent
mieux se vacciner davantage se vacciner
qui puisse y avoir plus d'accompagner
polémiques ont le sentiment d'un
traitement différencié s'il s'était
passé la même chose dans n'importe quel
autre département région de métropole le
gouvernement ne s'y serait pas rendu
écoutez c'est la petite polémique parce
que le sujet de savoir à quelle date le
ministre des autres maires de y
retourner précisément ces deux petites
polémiques ce qui compte c est ce que le
sujet est gérée est ce que l'ordre est
bien tenue la réponse est oui ça c'est
un sujet de sécurité intérieure
davantage qu'un sujet de ministère de
l'outre-mer dans un premier temps quand
on vous tu en as l'impression quand même
que le problème n'est pas que sanitaire
non je viens de vous le dire j'ai
effectivement de sécurité oui oui rien
sujet de sécurité mais aussi un
sentiment
d'abandon
mais je les connais que les départements
de métropole mais le sujet ultra marin
est un sujet éminemment complexe dans
notre pays et sap a commencé avec la
crise qu vide moi je suis un portage
d'arles du budget je peux vous dire que
l'état français est particulièrement
attentif au développement économique en
outre-mer à la situation sociale en
outre-mer qui est très différente en
fonction de quels départements ou quelle
communauté quelle collectivité on parle
donc là dessus je cite ici fallait
rassurer une dernière fois évidemment
que la politique pour les autres maires
de ce gouvernement elle est totalement
offensive elle est totalement dans
l'accompagnement est totalement dans le
soutien c'était avant de parler du drame
qui s'est déroulé à calais fabien
roussel quel candidat communiste à la
présidentielle qui est actuellement en
déplacement dans les antilles dick
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
devraient être adaptées à la situation
de l'île est ce que vous entendez ça ou
est-ce que vous resté inflexible a tué
le ministre d outre mer a dit lui-même
qu'il regarderait au cas le cas certain
nombre de situations complexes et faut
agir avec discernement quand nos
responsabilités il faut pas faire les
choses de manière brutale et et en se
mettant des oeillères jeu sera pas le
cas mais il se trouve que l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants est une
nécessité c'est une nécessité pardon
mais pour la sécurité sanitaire des
patients c'est une nécessité donc nous
assumons cette politique là vous m'avez
posé la question il ya quelques minutes
de faut-il faire l'obligation vaccinale
pour tous nous pensons pour les
soignants c'est une nécessité pour
protéger d'abord les patients et pour
les protéger évidemment eux mêmes donc
ça nous maintenons après qu'il y ait un
regard aucun le cas par cas individuel
je crois que c'est de la bonne politique
sinon il faudrait pas d'hommes et de
femmes politiques il faudrait juste des
algorithmes on va parler de falla oui
autres sujets noirs dans l'actualité la
mort de ces 27 migrants à calais qui
tentait de traverser là la manche à
destination du royaume uni le ministre
de l'intérieur point que la
responsabilité des passeurs toute
l'action du gouvernement d'ailleurs
semblent centrés là dessus il ya une
solution européenne à ça ce problème
avec à au royaume uni qui est hors du
jeu européen bien sûr que c'est un c'est
une difficulté supplémentaire le break
site dans ce contexte là mais c'est
d'abord un drame humain c'est d'abord un
effroyable drame humain qui reflète
toute la difficulté que nous avons à
traiter cette cette situation qui ne
pourra être réglé que de façon
communautaire que de façon collective
vous le savez bien depuis que le royaume
uni mais plus d'ubs line et comme on dit
dans le jargon c'est une difficulté
supplémentaire à laquelle nous devons
effectivement faire face
qu'elle est qu'elle est la problématique
l'oubli n'est pour préciser ces les
accords de dublin c'est le pays alors
nous avons nous avons des accords en
cours à ceux du touquet est-ce qu'il
faut les repenser justement à l'aune du
prêt qui régissent la frontière entre
risque
on serre la frontière pour le royaume
uni est là dessus est ce qu'il faut le
repenser peut-être en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que on ne peut pas se
satisfaire de la situation actuelle
combien de drames va-t-on déploré avant
de régler cette situation mais il ya
plusieurs problèmes là dedans mais c'est
uniquement de la responsabilité des
passeurs il ya une responsabilité de la
politique migratoire française la
politique migratoire française elle ne
peut pas résoudre à elle seule cette
problématique là c'est malheureux
migrants ils veulent aller au
royaume-uni temps qu'ils passent par la
france c'est ça la réalité et il y à un
réseau de passeurs et là-dessus gérald
harman a raison de dénoncer les
criminels qui met ces personnes dans des
situations absolument dramatique en
danger de mort et malheureusement dans
certains cas c'est ce qui se passe et
donc oui nous devons absolument
harceler ses réseaux de passeurs et nous
avons besoin de toutes les forces en
présence dans ces lieux là quand nous
essayons de démanteler justement et de
disperser certain nombre de ceux qu'on
appelle les camps de migrants autour des
lieux de passage c'est justement pour
essayer d'empêcher cette facilité qu'ont
les pacers à les regrouper des personnes
et à aller organiser leur trafic nous on
lutte contre ça nous on lutte contre les
réseaux de passeurs avec le ministre de
l'intérieur ça doit rester notre
priorité mais ne nous leurrons pas cette
problématique ne se résoudra pas que
dans la lutte contre les passeurs s'il
n'y a pas une vraie résolution
collective du sujet migratoires et bien
malheureusement duras tournée de
migrants qui voudront passer au royaume
uni parce que est aussi une hypocrisie
de la part de la grande bretagne là de
problèmes il ya une hypocrisie aussi
parce que économiquement
son besoin aussi d'une certaine main
d'oeuvre économique et ça se sait et ces
migrants là ils veulent aller au royaume
uni ils veulent pas aller ailleurs ils
veulent aller au royaume uni donc il
faut aussi qu'on a un discours collectif
en confiance avec la grande bretagne qui
mérite d'être rançonnés a pas de
confiance à leurs actions je pense que
ça mériterait effectivement d'être
largement améliorée pour vous la réponse
c'est en grande partie européenne on l'a
compris on voit ce qui se passe en
pologne est-ce qu'il faut que l'europe
durcit ses frontières mais l'europe a
des frontières l'europe a des frontières
la frontière polonaise pour le cas
biélorusse c'est la frontière européenne
donc l'europe a des frontières s elle
doit aller renforcer sa sera à l'agenda
notamment de la présidence française de
l'union européenne sur le premier
semestre 2022
la réponse pour moi c'est toujours la
même c'est que l'europe a une
responsabilité aussi dans ses valeurs et
ce diptyque qui est celui des valeurs
européennes à savoir toujours
l'humanisme mais aussi la fermeté doit
toujours toujours prévaloir et ceux qui
passent à la frontière bélarus doit
toujours nous interpeller et nous avons
toujours être en capacité à regarder la
situation des êtres humains qui sont en
souffrance là dessus et en même temps la
frontière européenne c'est un enjeu
c'est un enjeu démographique c'est un
enjeu économique et social et oui
l'europe a aussi évidemment une
responsabilité collective dans la
fermeté vis-à-vis de s'effrondrer
l'autre sujet de tension entre français
rémi sella question de la pêche et de
ses licences de pêche qui sont
nécessaires désormais aux pêcheurs
français pour aller pêcher dans les eaux
britanniques
le conflit n'est toujours pas réglé
aujourd'hui les pêcheurs france ont
décidé de passer à l'action d'exprimer
leur colère ils vont bloquer trois ports
de la manche saint malo ouistreham
calais ils vont aussi bloqué le trafic
de fret dans le tunnel sous la manche
vous soutenez leurs actions la france
soutient des pêcheurs depuis le début
méthode de bloquer le trafic écoutez je
comprends la colère des pêcheurs tout le
monde comprend la colère des pêcheurs
encore une fois regarder la situation
dans laquelle le break site nous mais
collectivement et donc celle des
pêcheurs en particulier et la france
n'abandonne pas il n'abandonnera pas nos
pêcheurs là dessus la parole du
président de la république du ministre
des affaires étrangères est claire là
dessus sauf que vous parlez de sanctions
ça fait plusieurs jours que la france
par neuf sanctions ces sanctions elles
ne sont toujours pas appliquées est ce
qu'à un moment la parole et être clair
mais les actes leçon non cotées les
discussions bilatérales entre la france
et le royaume uni à son complexe sont
multiples mais elles ont lieu le
dialogue évidemment se poursuit mais on
en a parlé sur le sujet migratoires tout
à l'heure je crois que là aussi un
rapport de confiance doit largement être
renforcée et améliorée pour la situation
des pêcheurs comme sur d'autres
situations mais en aucun cas et je crois
que ce soit emmanuel macron que ce soit
clément mode que soit annick girardin à
aucun moment à aucun moment un seul
discours n'a laissé penser que nous
abandonnerons en aux pêcheurs on va
parler du budget évidemment puisque le
sénat a donc choisi de ne pas voter le
budget de ne pas aller au bout de
l'examen ils ont rejeté la première
partie ça fait tomber le reste du texte
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de cette
méthode les sénateurs il juge le budget
électoraliste oui je note surtout que
les sénateurs ne veulent pas nous dire
quelles dépenses il ne fallait pas faire
dans le budget de l'état pour 2022 c'est
pour ça qu'ils n'ont pas examiné la
partie des portes c'est une réaction
électoraliste de leur part écoutez c'est
toujours la même chose les as l'air qui
sont ça ne vous a pas échappé en
campagne interne nous disent qu'on
dépense trop dont acte moi je leur
demande citez moi une ligne budgétaire
sur laquelle vous seriez prêt soit
renoncer sans diminuer le montant
silence radio silence radio pourquoi
parce qu'ils savent très bien qu'il faut
augmenter le budget de la justice ce
qu'ils savent très bien qu'il faut
augmenter le budget de la sécurité parce
qu'ils savent très bien qu'il faut mieux
rémunérer nos professeurs et nous
soignons parce qu'ils savent très bien
qu'on a vu à renforcer notre politique
d' aide au développement justement pour
anticiper les problématiques migratoires
en fait les oppositions savent que nous
faisons un bon budget mais comme ils
sont en campagne ils ont besoin de dire
que nous dépensons trop et comme ils ne
veulent pas se dédire eh bien il se
trouve qu'effectivement il est plutôt à
l'aise il est plutôt pratique de ne pas
vouloir débattre de la partie dépenses
personnellement je trouve que ce n'est
pas de bonne politique et que ce n'est
pas très responsable scéniquement de la
campagne sur le budget rectificatif par
exemple ils ont fait des propositions
travers les sénateurs il n'était pas
d'accord avec vous sur l'indemnité
inflation juste et l'indemnité promise
par jean castex pour les 38 millions de
français gagnent moins de 2000 euros par
mois et qui vont donc recevoir une
indemnité inflation de san roque ça a
été voté par le parlement les sénateurs
ils ont dit c'est mal ciblés c'est mal
calibré ça coûte trop cher ils ont
proposé d'autres mesures que vous avez
rejeté et notamment sur le fait que
cette indemnité ne tenait pas compte des
revenus du ménage mais c'était
individuel pourquoi vous ne les avez pas
entendu là-dessus pourquoi vous n'avez
pas cherché à comprendre vous savez
combien de français auraient été
bénéficiaires de l'indemnité inflation
dans la version du sénat beaucoup moins
qu'à 38 millions de france 8 millions de
français moi je dis aux 30 millions de
français qui vont être bénéficiaires de
l'indemnité inflation parce que
l'assemblée nationale heureusement
rétabli la version initiale du texte
qu'ils auront bien qu'ils auront bien là
euros sur l'injustice non mais attendez
là encore halte à l'hypocrisie on peut
pas dire au début de l'automne il faut
vite réagir face à l'inflation face à la
hausse des prix du carburant les élèves
eux mêmes demandé un chèque énergie
inflation carburant vous l'appelez comme
rouler et quand nous le faisons ils
disent c'est mal ciblés on va le réduire
de 38 millions de français à 8 millions
de français c'est pas sérieux à un
moment donné quand on est dans une
situation aussi critique que celle que
la france connaît aujourd'hui au
lendemain de la crise alors qu'on a une
forte dynamique économique alors qu'on
n'a jamais eu un chômage aussi bas alors
qu'on protège le pouvoir d'achat des
français je pense que collectivement
même si tout n'est pas parfait et
qu'évidemment démocratie faut qu'on
s'oppose et je crois que collectivement
on peut aussi reconnaître que quand les
mesures sont jugées utiles est bonne au
bon moment on peut aller voter ensemble
je déplore que le sénat l'a pas fait
c'est une forme de maintien du quoi
qu'il en coûte non parce que c'est
vraiment une réaction
transitoire exceptionnelle à un effet
conjoncturel que l'inflation sur les
prix de l'énergie on est vraiment sur
quelque chose de particulier la reprise
économique dans le monde soudaine et
global fait qu'effectivement vous avez
des effets inflationnistes sur l'énergie
bon eh bien nous avons deux choix soit
nous disons c'est qu'une année le
portefeuille des français devra
l'amortir ça nous disons c'est injuste
et au lendemain d'une crise qui a déjà
été complexe on estime que le pouvoir
d'achat des français doit être préservé
et donc au fait effectivement une aide
exceptionnelle de 200 euros je vous
accorde que c'est un coût pour la
collectivité 3,8 milliards d'euros
croyez moi c'est pas une mince affaire
mais nous avons jugé cela nécessaire
d'abord pour le portefeuille destitué
vous même en tant que rapporteur général
de la commission des finances que vous
êtes inquiet pour la dette de la france
je ne suis pas inquiet mais je suis
vigilant je le dis depuis que j'ai pris
ses fonctions la dette de la france est
soutenable la signature française sur
les marchés est excellente il n'y a pas
de risque à court moyen terme que
l'endettement français nous fasse si
vous voulez mettre en risque
collectivement sur une dette qui serait
tout d'un coup payer beaucoup plus cher
ou sanctionner ou sur laquelle nous
devrions prendre des mesures d'austérité
de hausse d'impôts sous dette tout ça
n'existe pas en revanche il faut rester
vigilant parce que l'avenir au lendemain
de la crise des finances publiques de la
france est un enjeu fondamental c'est un
enjeu de souveraineté d'indépendance
si le prochain gouvernement
les prochains gouvernements ne savent
pas démontré une maîtrise un sérieux
budgétaire un assainissement de nos
comptes publics la réduction des
déficits la stabilisation de la dette la
réduction de la dette à terme alors
effectivement ce que vous pointez du
doigt pourra devenir une inquiétude à
terme aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
inquiétude il ya de la maîtrise il ya du
sérieux budgétaire et pour que ça dure
je crois qu'il faut laisser ceux qui
savent le faire aux responsabilités un
mois de la présidentielle pour terminer
la maison commune verra donc le jour où
landis
la république en marche le modem agir
horizon partie d'edouard philippe la
maison commune c'est plutôt une addition
de chapelles non la maison commune
ensemble le citoyen c'est d'abord un
formidable mouvement pour montrer que
nous on est réunie derrière un futur
candidat qui se déclara qu il faudra se
déclarer et pendant que d'autres se
séparent se départagent choisissent des
personnes plutôt que des idées bien nous
nous montrons inverse c'est à dire que
nous nous réunissons nous étions déjà
ensemble mais nous le faisons de façon
facile d'y revenir quand on arrive dans
un unique sortant reconnaissez quand on
est dans l'opposition oui mais c'est
aussi le fruit d'années travail qui au
lieu de nous avoir divisé comme c'est
arrivé dans beaucoup de majorité par le
passé je vous rappelle pas les frondeurs
même je vous rappelle pas sous le
quinquennat 2007 il y avait eu
évidemment des fractures internes aussi
et bien nous nous sommes soudés nous
sommes une grande équipe son tour du
président de la république effectivement
depuis les soutiens d'enseignement à
gauche jusqu'au soutien anciennement à
dreux n'espériez pas davantage de la
république en marche c'est à dire en
termes de partis politiques là la
république en marche c'est un jeune
parti le savez la vie politique c'est du
long terme ce n'est pas à vous que je
vais la prendre nous avons créé ce
mouvement en 2016 au tour d'emmanuel
merkel à la maison celui de sema l'échec
de la
république
c'est une composante majeure sinon
central de cette maison commune et nous
savons bien que
regarder à l'assemblée nationale vous
avez
280 ou 82 députés qui sont dans le
groupe de la république en marche la
république au marshall facebook au début
du quinquennat reconnaissez le vous qui
parlez français c'est comme dans tout
mandat vous avez des personnes qui
changent de groupe évidemment mais la
république en marche c'est pas c'est pas
qu'une étiquette c'est aussi un adn
c'est aussi une façon de faire de la
politique beaucoup plus ancrée dans la
société civile et avec ses citoyens ça
ça nous a jamais quitté et je veux
évidemment qu'au sein de la maison
commune cet état d'esprit perdure merci
beaucoup merci saint martin d'avoir été
invité ce matin
[Musique]